Jamie it's interesting it's a
fascinating story I've been digging into
it but if you look at a 30 billion
dollar market cap to raise just 500
million I mean don't you feel like they
could have raised more maybe they could
you know it's really about the the cash
needs for the investment you know the
CFO it kind of indicated maybe they
didn't need to if they executed
perfectly the the billion and change
that they have on the books might be
enough but having an extra half billion
and cushion without having to tap the
credit line seems at least prudent and
so so they're taking some money while
they can I thought it might have been a
billion or two but half a billion
certainly is is going to be helpful
because they're investing they've got to
launch the Model X you know this quarter
really ramped it up next quarter they're
trying to build this massive battery
factory near Reno that they call the
gigafactory and then they've got to
develop a more mass market like car you
know the the model 3 to try to compete
with the 3 series and and try to really
get some scale there's huge investments
coming ahead for this company so an
extra half a billion to get them through
until the Model X starts generating some
cash seems seems like a wise move Jamie
can we infer that investors investors
aren't always happy when companies
dilute them by selling new equity but
should investors feel reasonably good
about the timing of this particular sale
or at least the announcement because the
bad news is out the door they i can
imagine they would have been furious at
tesla tried to sell the stock north of
280 before that disappointing earnings
report maybe I mean obviously it would
have been better to get to a diaz share
than to get 2 30 or 2 40 but you know
the shares were up early this morning
and I think that shows just like we were
talking about that that there is a sense
of that that is a good move to give them
a little extra cushion even though it's
diluting the value of their shares they
think they're better off because there's
less of a chance of a downside less of a
chance that they start running short on
cash and have to go get money when it's
really expensive you know people talk
about range anxiety as the biggest
problem for the biggest challenge not
only the Tesla but to electric cars in
general I think the biggest challenge
that means what it's just that that
people are worried that they will
run out of charge and not find any place
to fill up and one of the reasons is a
lot of people think there aren't enough
places to fill up one of the things
Tesla is doing I'm sure with this
investment but also already is putting
in a lot more charging stations for
example here in Manhattan yeah Tesla's
been investing really heavily in their
supercharger network which are the
really really high powered fast chargers
that they put along highways that they
intend for people to use for long
distance road trips so that you could
actually drive a Model S or Model X
across the country or you know take it
to Grandma's house in another time zone
there now adding according to new york
times they're adding these stations
throughout manhattan where you can pay
to get a reasonably fast charge not as
fast as the supercharger but faster than
just plugging into a regular wall outlet
they also had these destination chargers
at nice hotels and restaurants and
Yosemite Park you know where you can go
and in charge up that are again sort of
in-between pace but they're free because
the company wants you to come visit them
charge up your Model S you know stay for
dinner well under a better band they're
going to need the money to expand in
China I mean the Chinese haven't come up
with a standardized charging system yet
Tesla said when they do they're going to
convert all their cars there that's
going to cost money and they you know
China is a very big country so they need
to put more supercharger and destination
charger stations there that's one of the
main concerns yeah list of a road trip
culture probably than in the US or even
in Europe but look I mean you're exactly
right Tesla has so many ambitions
globally so many challenges you this is
this is the company of you know 20
impossible things and they've done like
eight but they have 12 more to go
they've got to expand into Europe they
had expand in China they've got to build
a supercharger network they've got to
get a retail network you know that they
can legitimately compete with the likes
of BMW and Mercedes without dealerships
while they're being fought you know on
these state and state legislatures that
there's a lot comparatives a lot to do
at Tesla and an extra half a billion or
an extra couple billion is going to help
them all right Jamie thanks very much
fast
story I love to talk about Tesla
obviously and you're right 20 impossible
things they've done ate a lot of people
have real issues with with the company
but I just think it's amazing to see the
products that they create